هو نقص في الادوات والبيئه لا تسمح بذلك
يعني انا اعود للوراء قليلا انت تجد
الطالب التاء من الدراسات العليا حفظ
مذكرات هنا وهناك لخصها وحفظها ودخلوا
ربما حصل على امتياز كما تفضلت هو عاوز
يبقى دكتور فيبدا يبحث يجي لحضرتك وييجي
لي يروح لفلان اديني موضوع يا ابني لابد
تنبع من ذاتك فكره احنا المفروض ان انت
عندك فكره عايز تعالجها في مشكله يعني بعض
الناس ينظر الى الرسائل علميه الى الان
لابد يكون 500 صفحه لابد يكون 600 صفحه
والموضوع ده يكلف كم صفحه يا اخي انظر ده
انا ممكن ادي واحد الدكتوراه في 50 صفحه
لكن جاء بمشكله وحلها يعني الرسائل
العلميه المفروض عشان تخدم الدوله وتخدم
المجتمع المفترض ان انت تاتي بمشكله او
تنبهنا على مشكله ستحدث عشان ننتبه لها
لكن كما قلت لك ياتي الباحث يبحث مننا
ياخد مننا يسال زميله يسال مش عارف يقول
لك الكليه تعمل له مشروع رسائل يختار له
بحث يجيبوا له مخطوطات
ويدخل الادوات العلميه عنده كما تفضلت مش
موجوده فمش عارف يبدا منين مش عارف يقرا
مش عارف يفهم مش عارف كذا كذا الى اخره
يعني مثلا انت عندك في مصر قامت ضجه من
سنوات على كتابات حامد نصر ابو زيد